hello and welcome to this video playing
winny pooh-pooh with white and term okay
the what is that called
Owens defense no he goes d6 it's art
it's an odd way to combine it yeah how
do we go here yeah I showed I definitely
want to play a3 pawn Center with either
f-4c form so I'm going for for this and
now at F foreign yep so he's going for
hippo hippopotamus d6 and so on I expect
to happen no go c5 no yeah I guess t5 is
okay going into a Benoni where I'm b6
and Bishop e7 is just wrong just doesn't
belong just belong there
okay that's interesting doesn't doesn't
even play a six yeah he probably wants
to go six and the near future now if you
play a four and black does not react you
should go away five really what I want
to do but I wonder if he has this cookie
six business it just really really
possible yeah it's so belongs into the
position or can you do and black now
basically has to check it and he does
check it so let's go towards the pawn
and e6 is what what I'm not sure about
that could actually be playable for
black okay doesn't
doesn't do it okay Wow
ignorance is bliss what is third is it
called yeah just he just ignores it
entirely what I'm doing
what is your move now okay so the UH
knight c6 looks excellent already just
just winsome material let's do it then
a7 is just dropping or is there anything
better maybe not no rabbit
okay what is c4 doing okay may detect my
bishop okay but other than that not much
yeah now should be seven looks right
because I don't see what is replies what
is the reply I mean taking looks very
scary but you have to do it almost
Knight b6 Bishop e3 is also absolutely
terrible
okay
let's see if I can keep that pawn if I
could keep the pawn on you be sad when a
game is just a one yeah
Queen a one looks like a decent choice
it should win material yeah now Queen
where a five or a seven the booth looks
good let's go a seven
yeah grab c4 or is there anything better
don't think yeah so where to put this
now to d3 problem
Queen a8 maybe what is the good square
here I want to keep the pawn I don't
want to give it up right away let's go
let's still b5 available if you text the
Queen again
95 now in the mix 95 Queen checks not
winning straight away that's a bit of a
pain yeah I'm not really winning it
immediately
Wow doesn't take the pawn that is a bit
crazy
ninety-seven is a good resource here
he has to take his son I mean no
question there okay yeah he didn't
really react to to what I was doing it's
in many ways okay so we got into this
this been known you it should be quite
favorable just because them Bishop on b7
as she's wrong in this position so like
this and I went a form just it's a
routine move and now a six a six is
basically the the reflexive reaction
because you have to just do it and now
b5 against a five but he did not react
and it might be possible to do that if
you play a quickie six so I wasn't sure
about all this like a five takes 92 the
movie six is critical and he didn't do
it yeah as you see the engine gives his
sixes okay for black this is why I was a
little bit in doubt about this whole
process I was just thinking okay when I
go if or if I go away for I kind of have
to play a five if he doesn't react but I
mean that's not truly the case the
engine just gives the Bishop c4 or
development which is probably better
than you know if he goes is six now
things are certainly very complicated
because I have a hard time to support
the center my pieces are somewhat
uncoordinated and in fact if I have to
take then all of a sudden I'm sorry and
cross one this Bishop of course gains a
lot you just did not react in any way
like like nothing ever happened
just allow me to take on a five this is
giving out basically the game how do you
defend us now with all those weaknesses
it just doesn't happen just is just very
bad
I probably could have executed this in a
stronger fashion between a one-night bah
queen a 5-4 stronger than queen a seven
it should not be a huge difference but I
think I made a mistake somewhere here
and b8 Queen
oh of course yeah why not yeah yeah yeah
b8 Queen is just strong yeah once what's
black supposed to play like this is
losing a piece yeah well here it's the
queen is hanging and the queen is
hanging anyway and like here will you
take on a fade one is seven delivery man
and then a seven okay so that that was
winning immediately and here I mean yeah
white should win but it's not so so easy
I should go 95 yeah that's a lot
stronger the King does in a lot stronger
now because like here if he just takes
Queen B seven I mean of course a
material up I take here a place can't
wait I guess I take and just go back and
I mean I'm I'm a poor enough but I mean
two points but be two before and you're
not winning this easily and Queen da to
suicide this no rook c8 and everything I
mean you cannot just allow white to keep
the b-pawn if you can avoid it
yeah that was the key moment is really
here he has to absolutely avoid avoid
the situation that I take a five and
have no counter play the most normal
thing I would have been to play a six so
that this move is never dangerous really
because of d5 you just don't know how
this I just prevent to say five push all
together okay thanks a lot for watching